- Des écoliers transformés
temporairement en radar vivant,
mais en toute sécurité,
une activité ludique pour
sensibiliser les automobilistes
à respecter les limites
de vitesse.
MÉLINA BEHLOILI, élève 6e année
École Paul-VI
- Il y a des gens qui
ralentissent puis il y en a
qui ne ralentissent pas,
mais la plupart ralentissent.
- Les élèves se relaient pour
participer à cette activité,
qui est organisée par
le Service de police de Laval.
Un élève tient le radar
dans sa main et la vitesse des
automobilistes est retransmise
sur le sac à dos d'une autre
écolière.
En vert, eh bien, la vitesse
est conforme, mais attention!
En rouge, elle dépasse
la limite.
BENOIT LOCAS, directeur,
École Paul-VI
- Moi, je trouve que c'est
du bonbon, c'est un plus
pour notre école,
pour notre organisation aussi,
le centre de services.
C'est la rentrée, septembre;
c'est le temps de penser à
la sécurité autour des écoles.
- Pour la police de Laval,
l'opération est un succès.
CHANTAL MOREAU,
Service de police de Laval
- On a des beaux impacts
qui sont positifs : les gens
ralentissent, les parents
également qui nous voient.
Ça amène une visibilité
policière sur les lieux,
sur place. Donc oui, on peut
considérer ça comme un outil
préventif efficace.
- Aucun constat d'infraction
n'a été émis par les policiers,
qui voulaient juste rappeler aux
automobilistes que la vitesse
permise dans les zones scolaires
est fixée à 30 km à l'heure.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, L